Unfortunately,
this time you are not having too many
people checking your paper.
So I find it unfortunate because when
it's a larger...
section, you have two,
three people checking,
one person checking each questions.
And then, you know,
if one person doesn't like your answer,
someone else likes your style of
answering. So it balances out.
Unfortunately, here, this won't happen.
There's going to be just one person who's
a very senior faculty member.
who's engaged,
you would have seen it on the site.
He's called a learning facilitator,
but he's been teaching courses with me
and he's...
Good, good to have.
He's worked in a very in very senior
positions in IT companies, and...
He knows the subjects very well.
So...
He's going to be evaluating your papers.
Just give me a minute.
Sir, we can't hear you.
Oh yeah. Now can you hear me?
Yes, sir.
So, you know,
every teacher has a distinct thing,
but I can assure you,
BITS Pilani has not given any such
instruction. Okay,
so BITS Pilani does not say that you have
to...
give marks by the weight of the paper
consumed or by quantum written.
That's not an instruction given.
But I can tell you one thing,
that there is a difference in evaluation.
I like to explain it to people. You know,
when you join a company,
Very often,
it's just your luck as to what is the
type of person you're working under.
And it just so happens you are the best
programmer or the best architect going
around,
and you just don't happen to get along
with your boss.
And the only choice you're left is to
Well, if it's a large enough company,
there'll be a process where you can say,
I want a transfer within the company.
If it's not a very big company,
you have to look elsewhere. So here,
at least you are lucky that you're going
to be doing a large number of courses.
And if one particular faculty member does
not like your style of answering,
you'll have to simply accept it.
But my recommendation is that write
clearly,
because some people will not have the
patience to try to figure out a
handwriting which is not legible.
Try to address the question clearly.
And make sure you're answering the
question and not beating it around the
bush.
Sometimes you start giving a lot of
background and this and that,
and by the time the person has read that,
the person comes to a conclusion that you
don't understand.
So try to give a clear-cut answer,
understand the question clearly.
Look for what is being asked for because
the questions are going to be fairly
pointed. They are not vague questions.
They may be case study based,
but a case study based question does not
mean that you can write about a cricket
match as an answer.
The answers are based on the concepts
that have been taught in the course.
So that you must remember that you have
to be steered by what you are learning.
Having said that...
This is a masters level course.
And as you get into higher level of
evaluation after masters,
you might do a PhD.
You'll be working in a company
practically.
More and more.
There's a variation of appreciation there.
Some people may not just appreciate your
line of thinking, and...
There is no one answer.
And it is your ability to put forth what
you're saying convincingly that gets you
through. Having said that,
even if you believe that you are
convincing,
you believe you said the right thing,
and the teacher believes,
the faculty evaluating believes that, no,
that
You are not focusing on the answer. Well,
the judgment is final.
Sometimes the only danger is some people
give papers for rechecking.
Read the answer key.
The answer key is provided.
Read it very carefully before giving for
rechecking,
because when a paper is rechecked,
It is checked a little more minutely
against the answer key,
and the marks don't necessarily go up.
Sometimes a teacher, out of five marks,
feels, okay,
this person seems to be doing something.
Okay, let's give one mark.
Then it comes for rechecking, saying that,
you know,
one mark is not good enough for me.
I'm in a pathetic position.
Give me at least two.
And when that question is reviewed by the
same faculty or someone else,
and they feel, oh, no,
this is why was that one mark given?
It can become a zero.
So don't just give a paper for rechecking.
And in my course,
I encourage the evaluators to deduct
marks if it appears as if the
reevaluation has been just requested
because it comes free of cost.
I do not know about Bombay University.
Whether they charge you money for
rechecking, which doesn't ask for money,
but the new mark can be less than the
previous.
Even the rechecking their procedures to.
What do you call it? Escalated.
Those procedures are extremely complex
and as a student of bits I tried it once
and...
The paper was sent to another university
for checking, and when it came back,
the comment was that the student has got
more marks than what he deserves, so...
What do you do after that?
So you just can't be haggling over marks.
Just make sure that you've learned
something in the course.
Now let's say interoperability.
Can we say?
Systems use different programming
languages, database, and technology,
but they can still communicate through
standard APIs or protocols, for example,
PRASAD API, JSON.
OAuth 2.0 is an authorization protocol.
HTTPS, right?
We can work together.
Yes, that is interoperability, right?
That's very much what interoperability is
that.
ANAND.
These.
And doesn't end at protocol.
It's also a question of having an
interface which is standard.
Like you can communicate over JSON,
but then if your JSON object definition.
If it is supposed to be for a variety of
systems,
there's got to be a standardization.
The government of India wants some data
in JSON.
The government of India may decide that,
okay, this is the...
protocol to be followed.
And you provide the data as per the
structure indicated by the Government of
India, the Income Tax Department say.
But if you want to write applications
which are absolutely for the open world,
And.
By and large, in every industry.
Standards are getting declared.
Like when we started works years back,
banks started computerizing.
Every bank thought of their own way of
handling things.
Gradually.
And today,
there's an absolute standard for...
Information exchange between banking
systems.
This is something you'll have to ask the
examination department,
that if you want answer keys for previous
papers. Unless you know some students,
this is something which we have not been
asked to give.
We've been asked to provide,
and that also we don't provide,
the examination department provides a
previous paper for you to look at.
And once you've appeared for the exam,
the answer key is shared.
Sahil,
the thing is now that we are not going to
run this course like a coaching center.
That's not going to be the approach.
But however,
if you want to see sample answers,
just give any question to Gemini and
gives you beautiful sample answers.
And I can assure you if you can give the
type of answers when he gives you,
you can get full marks.
Okay, so thank you.
Yeah, yeah, so...
Wasn't a bother to you, but yeah,
this is just curious.
No, no, no, no, no, you've been honest.
You've asked and the answer I've given
you is also honest. You try it.
I don't know whether you've tried Gemini
or not.
I did not hear.
Because, yeah, because Bits Milani,
we have been provided an AI tool.
which generates questions and generates
answers and evaluation rubrics. Okay,
and it's a fantastic job.
I don't know which large language module
they are using at the back,
but it brings out the answers crystal
clear. So.
And you know the...
Answer keys that will be shared with you
have also been generated by the AI tool.
So I don't know what they did in your B,
whether during your B,
the teacher set the papers or they have a
question bank set by a large number of
teachers. But here in BITS Pilani,
the institute made it very clear that we
have to use the AI tool.
So once the AI tool generates the
questions, then we vet it.
We take a look at it,
make sure that it's not something which
is outside the syllabus.
Make sure that it is worded properly.
And it takes a lot of input, you know.
The teachers who set the papers,
they have to give diagrams.
They have got to give text materials,
slides.
All that has to be provided as a resource
to the tool.
And the tool generates questions,
the question paper, the answer key,
and the evaluation rubric.
So that's how things are working these
days.
And if you focus too much on the
examination,
it's going to be a bit difficult.
And definitely a master's level program
doesn't have questions which are like,
maybe I did my B years back, but.
Those days,
if we prepared for 20 questions,
almost you got a similar question in the
examination paper.
But the emphasis in a masters code would
be that, well,
any question that comes this year should
not be similar to any question that has
come in the last 10 years. Because...
You can ask about anything. Today,
there's a question about a hospital.
Tomorrow, it will be about a dispensary,
maybe an aircraft.
And then variations in quality attributes,
take any tactics,
make a question you want to ask about how
to...
achieve availability. Given a case study,
given some background factors.
How would you present an availability
scenario from there?
So you should be able to draw the
availability scenario out.
So that would be a thing.
Where can you see the quiz evaluation
rates? Can somebody answer this?
I'm also not sure.
I got it, sir. I got, I got it, sir.
Thank you very much.
You.
I got the answer from the ab now,
and we can see it in the review.
If you can share your answer for this,
because other people will have the same
problem as you,
if you can just mention it as to how it
should be seen,
where do you have to click?
It's on the quiz actually, when you,
when we click on the quiz that we
attempted,
there is an option for the review.
So, so that shows the, you know, grades,
actually, how many blocks.
Okay.
So they appear at the same place where
the quiz was. Okay. Yeah,
because I don't have, yeah. Yeah,
Yes, yes, I can share this screenshot.
you could.
Then you'll end up sharing your marks.
Thank you.
You don't have to. Privacy concern.
If you would have no problem sharing,
Ohh, no problem, no problem.
nobody would have problems looking at it.
But I wouldn't.
Ask you to do it, you're welcome to.
OK, click on review, says uh, you've said,
yeah, that's the thing is.
OK, sir, got it, thank you, sir.
So basically,
there's a review when we click on the
quiz. When we click on the quiz one,
for example,
Yeah, yeah.
Right, right, right. Right, right, right.
Okay, okay, okay. SUBBANNAVAR.
there's a review link down below and
there it appears.
So,
so I have one question for the for the
So, yeah.
Yeah.
mid mid this mid sem exam.
So generally what happens in the previous
Right.
semester that we appeared for half of the
subject. For example, there are 16 units.
So for 8 units, so we were, you know,
supposed to appear for the mid semester
Two.
and post.
8 sessions,
then we appeared for the comprehensive.
That's going to be same for this subject
as well in this.
A subtle misunderstanding there.
I've been teaching in BITS for years and
years and years.
Immediately after I passed out as a
student, I started teaching.
And I've stayed six years in BITS
attending courses.
Never in no course is a comprehensive
exam supposed to be on 8.
on the last eight.
And this is a misunderstanding,
some maybe on the part of the students or
on top part of the faculty.
The comprehensive exam by the very name,
it's comprehensive.
Okay.
It is on the entire syllabus.
It is not on the last eight. Okay.
Okay.
Yeah,
so if it is a misunderstanding created,
it is a misunderstanding. Now,
let me tell it to you in a different way.
You know,
I don't want to sound complicated.
What you do in the last eight...
Sessions.
is derived from what you have done in the
first state. In the first state,
we normally cover fundamentals.
And you cannot build the last date
without knowledge on the first date.
And when you are answering questions on
the last date,
if you are not very sure-footed about the
first date,
you cannot attempt those questions.
So if you now go back and look at the
question papers,
which are then the comprehensives,
you cannot say that
You know you didn't require knowledge on
the first date.
No.
Ring.
You find that first eight tend to be pure
theory. Lots of...
concepts are put across and that is why
it is closed book because we want those
concepts to be memorized.
But thereafter,
when you are attempting the next eight
session.
And in this particular course,
the level of abstraction will go much
higher. See, over here,
I'm talking about quality attributes,
a very clear-cut quality attributes,
very clear-cut tactics. They are diagrams.
So the course is very crystal clear.
But once we shift onto CS9 onwards,
We'll be talking about patents.
And you won't even know which patent you
should apply where.
And the moment you have a practical
example, okay, in this case,
what pattern will you use?
In an examination situation,
it's still possible to guess because the
question has been sent in such a way just
to check your knowledge. So
You more or less know that, okay,
in this type of a case,
you will have to use so and so pattern.
But...
The reality is, when you in a case study.
How you decide which pattern to use is
something which will not be very clear
cut.
It will not be something like applying a
formula. And the applications themselves,
the depth to which we cover it.
And the depth to which you understand it
will differ from person to person.
TOM.
And that's why we make it open book,
because we expect,
don't expect people to know so many
things via art,
but we expect people to have gone through
the course adequately to be able to spot
where they should go and look for the
answer.
So, yeah.
But the thing is, the thing is, like,
if I recall,
if I recall the first session that we had,
so you,
Right.
I remember that you said that for the,
you know, the open book exam,
it is not possible to, you know,
get back with all the prints,
because in the content is very huge and
we have a lot of theory,
it won't be it won't be easy to shuffle
the pages and...
Yeah.
Turn around, check the answer,
and write it.
It's better to better to have the concept
clear, and we have to memorize the things,
No, no,
I don't say you have to memorize the
you know.
things.
You need to have gone through them.
You know,
there's some people who go equipped with
a huge bundle of papers,
hoping that during the exam they'll find
out the answer somewhere.
Unless you've gone through the entire
material, you won't know where to look.
Yeah.
Okay, that's what I'm trying to emphasize.
So, so would it would it be worth?
Would it be worth to get the print end
appear in the example of the open book?
You'll find it very difficult to manage
without the print either.
Ohh.
Okay,
so the least is you should carry the
print of the because in a course like
this.
It is safer to carry the print of the
slides than to carry the textbook because
once you go to CS9 onwards.
Lots of material is not covered in the
main textbook,
mostly internet references or references
to different books.
Okay.
So, when you,
you really feel lost if you try to carry
textbooks,
then a lot of outside references involved.
So, so, so generally, I am,
I am very afraid, you know,
Yeah.
when I see the lot of content to look
around and appear for exam, because I,
I'm not so, so all of us.
You should, you should index your book,
index it properly,
you should know what is where.
Go through it.
The approach suggested by me for such a
course,
because I've done a lot of courses myself
for bits, I've taught them,
I've studied there. No, I normally...
Every book.
that has been prescribed as a textbook.
Well, when I was a student,
I was a full-time student.
I've read the books cover to cover,
even without understanding,
but I've not skipped anything.
Now, once you do that,
then you start reading selectively.
So my suggestion would be go through the
slides cover to cover even without
understanding them so that you know what
lies where.
But the thing is,
there won't be direct questionnaire.
And.
There's a, there's another thing.
There won't be a direct question.
The.
It will be a kind of a scenario will be
asked.
See,
sometimes if you know a subject well
enough,
the same question appears direct to you.
Yeah.
And to a person who has no clue about the
subject, who's hoping that, okay,
it's open book,
I'll go and manage somehow.
I've been very busy.
Then you suddenly find that there's no
direct question.
So how direct you find the question is
dependent on
The way you look at it,
Anupam Sarkar is trying to ask something.
Got it, sir, got it.
Yes, Anupam.
Yes, the question is,
so we are sharing those slides currently
for each of those sessions.
Are there going to be different sets of
Right, right.
slides before we go for the exam?
Because we understood that it is going to
Excellent, excellent. Very good question.
Very, very good question.
be watermark.
Don't spend your money printing these
slides just now,
because because a comprehensive,
they are going to give us a new watermark.
Okay.
Okay, so that will get before the exams.
Okay.
Content would be same, right? The slides.
Content will be same,
content will be same,
but if you've taken the effort and the
expenditure on printing it,
you will not be allowed to carry it in
without the watermark. Yeah,
HARI.
that's the only problem.
So, that's really good. OK.
I think,
I think there is no way to get the
printer up and to get those slides in the
beginning, I mean, right now,
because generally, generally.
Look,
you can you can raise the request to the
examination department and why don't you
share the watermark with the faculty now,
so that we can start printing. So,
I said the other thing is that they
The.
normally ask us to give the entire
watermark slide set as a single deck.
Either they create it for us or we have
to create it,
Yeah, yes.
so it'll come as a single set,
and these sites slides, you know,
though we do reuse slides,
that changes being made due over the
semester.
So.
All the slides are not ready with the
faculty at this stage. Of course,
if BITS decides that we have to have the
slides ready,
then a slide set will be provided.
So this is something for the everything
is process oriented.
Different people are owning different
processes and.
The examination department operating
under the dean takes these decisions as
to what watermark when. In fact,
what has happened is that we started
using the old watermark and then we got
instructions saying that it's quite
useless because the new watermark will be
given to you near the end of the course.
And that has to be applied. Okay.
But honestly speaking,
I don't think that anyone is checking the
print out at the examination center.
I have not seen because...
That,
that is that is a privilege you have got.
I have the privilege of looking.
I have not seen anyone being checked.
What are what are what are what are we
carrying out?
Because in the previous Semester,
Well...
Well, I can tell you,
I know of one particular center,
the all the exams.
No, I will check.
I know one particular center where a
re-examination is being held.
Ohh.
Okay.
For all the students.
No, I think I will do it.
Yeah,
all for a particular center because they
have got a bulk malpractice in one
particular center.
My GARG.
I've heard about it. Okay.
It was very nice when it happened,
somebody put a pencil mark.
Yeah, so, and and you know the you know,
it's a question of, like in Hindi,
they say, "Chore police," no,
when people get smarter by to misuse
technology,
there are people who are controlling it.
For example, I tell you, I'm a developer,
and on a particular application,
my client decided to go in for a security
and vulnerability audit.
And they've been doing it for the last 10
years. Every year,
and every year there are new
vulnerabilities. And of course,
you have regular scrutiny also.
We run our scrutinies to make sure.
But in the last one year, particularly,
we find that the vulnerabilities have
exploded. Why have they exploded?
Because the tools which catch the
vulnerability, they become very powerful.
They are using AI.
And the other reason...
Why it has become more important to
attend to this vulnerability is that the
people who are attacking the websites
have become smarter.
They're using AI to attack.
So if you are using AI to attack,
you need AI to catch them.
And then vulnerabilities which used to be
ignored, which were not even noticed,
You can't help but notice them and plug
them.
So today the responsibility as far as
security is concerned. Lester,
since all of you are IT people.
We've all heard about DevOps.
Now everybody is talking about DevOps and
there's a lot of work going on with
DevOps practices.
In the last two years,
we hear only about DevSecOps.
The security people are insisting it
should be a part of the automation
pipeline.
You've got to build in security into the
development operations process.
It cannot be something which is done on
parallel. And the moment you have a patch,
it has got to go through a complete
security evaluation before it can be put
up. And it's become very serious.
I have friends and
people known to me who are working with
banks,
and banks have really got paranoid about
the security requirements.
It's really becoming a concern.
And same with bits.
One fine day,
you might suddenly find that Bits has got
a scanner which they randomly scanned
your books and they know that your
watermark is not matching the requirement.
And then what happens to you?
So you assume that people are lax,
you walk in with a lax attitude,
maybe in one semester.
bits was lax and next time they are not,
then what do you do about it?
So we should not discuss about what BITS
doesn't do or what approach is possible
to bypass the system.
Because you cannot say that the police
did not catch that thief.
So today I'm also a thief, let me go.
You know, the day you are caught,
then you are the thief.
So let's understand that the systems,
the procedures that BITS has got in place,
we simply got to follow it. Okay, so
Writing practice going on. OK,
when you have to write your answers,
I thought you were allowed to type them
also.
We can do, we can do either, sir,
like if we are, if we are.
Arena was.
Yeah. So normally,
normally many people have approached
their followers, of course,
except for the people who are doing
handwriting practice like RAJ,
you come out with a beautiful handwriting.
If you are somebody like me,
whose handwriting can hardly be,
I'm not even a doctor and I need a.
The pharmacist to read my handwriting,
so I'm happy at typing,
and maybe after so many years of working
in IT, you know, one is lost.
The habit, so...
What happens is the diagrams,
if you draw a diagram,
it's best to scan it and put it up.
But the rest of the thing,
if you can type neatly,
some people are not too good in typing
either. They don't indent properly,
they don't paragraph properly.
It can be a problem.
Only watermarked dfdf. Absolutely right.
Why are we getting so worried about the
exam so early in the day?
We are only on the 4th session.
Yeah, so but eight session,
I assume we have exams and four sessions
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
are already there,
so it doesn't feel it in that long,
This is the fourth session.
Don't worry about the exam.
so yeah.
But the thing is that we are worried is,
as you said,
that we have to be very clear about the
answers and all now I'm thinking that how
we should approach the question and what
should we approach because we never
thought about the examination, you know,
as we are still in the beginning.
But we are not thinking like we should be
very clear,
Okay.
we should be very attentive in the class.
Okay, then no, no, no, no,
you don't have to be attentive in the
No.
class or anything.
Let me tell you now a flip side.
In other universities,
people compared with other universities,
you've got to score a certain number of
marks.
To get even an average score.
Like they say,
passing with the second division or
something in bits, it's relative,
so you just stay with the crowd.
No, staying with the ground.
Like, I give you an example last time.
That.
And you've seen the scores in the quiz.
People are getting 13, 14, 15.
So if that is your standard of your
students,
it's not the problem with the course or
with the teacher.
The problem is your peer.
And you are appearing for this course
with people who are technologists,
who've got at least one or two years of
experience in an IT company.
Some of you are more.
You're so crude up with technology.
And if there's any room to use any tools
to be able to answer quizzes,
JANRAO experts are doing it. So if...
There, there is Gemini or...
copilot or Claude to be used,
you all seem to be all experts because if
110 people are going to get near full
marks out of 190,
I must be sitting with a very,
very crewed up batch of students.
So the problem is not with the
examination or with the thing.
It's your batchmates.
So when you appear for the exam,
at least at that time,
Gemini is not going to be there.
So I can assure you,
the marks are not going to be 14 out of
15. If it is.
30 marks paper.
I assume the average should be 10 to 15.
because you have to have an exceptionally
good answer to be able to get full marks.
And if the entire batch is around 10, 15,
like they say among in good people,
even a secret is good.
Like it's the example I give people is
that
If you land up running in the Olympics,
you must be somebody good.
So you're running against a good peer.
And a teacher like me,
I am not bothered with the A graders.
I want a good C grade.
So my encouragement is try to understand
the concepts, develop a vocabulary,
Read through the slides so that I have an
average student who,
at the end of this course.
remember something about software
architecture. That's all.
I'm not bothered about competitive
students who want to be Mr.
India or be a gold medalist.
That's not my focus.
And if you're focused like that,
you'll have to find a different way to
approach it.
Yes, we'll take one more question then,
Anupam,
you're wanting to say something again.
Yes, sir, one more question. So, I mean,
when we have started now with this
Yeah.
working professional situation and we're
going through all these courses and we're
Yeah.
Right.
seeing the materials coming. Now,
to me at least, it seems that, I mean,
Yeah.
if I try to go and study beyond the
slides or...
Mm.
Any references or any of those sort?
I don't think I'll have enough time to do
Mm.
that.
So is there enough assurance that if
Mmh.
somebody goes through the slides that the
professors or teachers are sharing,
Right.
would be a good resource to clear the
exams?
Oh, clear the exams.
You have to do nothing.
Just appear for the quizzes,
do the assignments, you'll clear the exam.
If that's what you're looking for,
I'm wasting my time with you.
So.
Clearing an exam, bits. See,
the moment you've got admission,
you've almost cleared the exam because we
are very lucky in bits.
We are getting pre-qualified people.
The people we are getting to study are
not the people who deserve to plug.
And the only way to plug a BITS exam is
if you're too busy with something else in
life, you can't prepare for the exam,
you can't look at the slides and you
can't do the quiz or the assignment.
Those are the people who plug.
So getting through is never a concern.
So please don't bother about that.
And most of you are attending the course
to further your careers,
Okay.
not to have a basic requirement to get a
degree.
So that should not be a concern at all.
But your concern should be
Do you know enough to be able to face an
interview at the end of the year and then
when you tell somebody I'm an M.
Tech in so and so area?
you can put up a respectable presentation.
That should be important.
So try to understand stuff in the
syllabus. Don't focus on the exam.
The moment you focus on the exam,
you leave out too many things.
It can be dangerous. Yeah, yeah.
Just don't focus. It's not worth it.
Yes. Thank you.
Because ultimately, you know,
a growth in a company and a growth in
your knowledge sphere is going to carry
you much further than the getting some
marks or not getting them.
Okay.
JOHNSON. Thank you.
Yeah, welcome.
So there's somebody who's giving,
sharing some sad news with us.
So I've not read it. I'm just,
I'll read it in a while.
I feel very sad reading things like that,
but I can sense there's something not
very pleasant over there.
Everyone said due to personal reasons,
yeah.
UMESH has shared some situation because
when people have a personal problem or
sometimes it's not personal,
it could be your office problem.
You'll end up in a situation where your
office cannot allow you to get off you.
You are in a very key position because
we've got students here who may be a vice
president in a company or maybe a
CEO attending this course so that he or
she is upgraded in technology,
but then suddenly your company is facing
a crisis and you just simply can't touch
anything.
That's bad luck.
Okay.
Now,
today we are going to move a little bit
into GIRI. So far,
we understood what is architecture,
we understood architectural influences,
we understood the concept of structures
which you go to present,
and we understood their views.
Whereby we can see the structures now.
In a typical,
like somebody mentioned the BE type of an
approach,
we would do exercises in drawing diagrams.
Let's draw some structural views. Now,
if we start doing that,
we'll spend the whole semester doing that.
So what I would suggest is go into the
internet, ask them,
Ask, ask for some structures,
some component connector views.
So you'll be able to see some of them and
just leave it at that because...
In this course,
we are not going to be bothered about the
syntax.
If you basically been able to identify
modules or identify communication between
units, we have served the purpose.
Then we talked about quality attributes.
We've taken some key quality attributes.
We talked about interoperability,
security, performance availability,
testability, modifiability, usability.
And we understood that to achieve these,
there are some tactics that are available.
And I suggested to you that you should
list out all the tactics and make sure
you know the meaning of each one of them.
Here we come about.
Architectures requirements.
When we talk about architectural
requirements.
Viet.
Trying to understand which of the
requirements that you have got have an
impact on architecture.
And if these requirements have an impact
on architecture,
how do we design the architecture?
And after designing it,
how do we document it?
Documentation is basically lots of
written material plus the three types of
views. You have the structure views,
the component connector view,
and the allocation view.
Requirements.
Who will give you the requirements?
And that is the biggest problem of an
architect.
Ostensibly, well,
the client wants something done,
the client better let us know.
The client believes they've informed you.
Okay, that's the biggest problem.
The second biggest problem is that you
think you've understood.
The reality is,
neither the client has been able to
convey to you,
and to the extent the client has tried to
convey, you have not understood.
So a good architect is 1 who can elicit
the requirements from the client.
A good architect should be able to
educate the client adequately to be able
to give the requirements.
You're very lucky if you have a qualified
architect sitting at the client end who
is very clear about the requirement and
who can present it to you properly.
That will not always
Be the case.
So do you have a requirement document?
So people say, no,
there's a beautiful document.
We call it the SRS.
Is a system requirement specification,
and it's got a very,
very clear-cut indication of what is we
developed to develop as per that.
and you can collect your payment.
Yes, and then done.
Because...
At least I've seen problems.
When you develop.
As per the requirement document,
and you go to install the system,
and it does not serve the purpose.
which you are supposed to serve.
Start the blimb game.
You show the document and say this is it,
we have done it exactly for the document.
He said, no,
you misunderstood the document.
We have explained it.
Besides the document,
we did a lot of explaining to you.
We told you exactly what it is.
You have written it wrongly in the
document.
Then, what do you do?
You have to interview the stakeholders.
Confirm very clearly.
As to what is really in the written in
the document.
And after a while,
we'll talk about agile technologies.
All of you are exposed to agile, I'm sure,
because every IT company either practices
agile or at least pays lip service to it.
So we all understand what is agile.
And one of the key things about Agile is
that...
We handled with the client.
and we demonstrate to the client what we
have understood.
So as we progress with the work,
the old-fashioned approach,
most of you would not have seen it,
but when I started my career,
it was very much working that way.
You would have a document signed up,
proper legal document,
and then we develop.
After one year of development,
we go to install.
And then we take feedback.
And then after taking the feedback,
we again go out for three months.
And we say, okay,
we attend to the feedback.
And sometimes we tell them, see,
this feedback,
Actually,
there are lots of new requirements that
have come in. We'll be charging you extra.
Some clients will be willing to
understand and agree to some addition.
Some clients will be very obstinate.
They say, no, you misunderstood.
You better do it in the same case.
So this sort of a situation,
we used to call it the late.
Break LATEBREAK break late break.
That's better.
That means the entire application breaks.
late in the development stage,
which means the consequences are that a
lot of rework has to be done.
An enormous amount of rework.
So if you had interviewed the
stakeholders,
interacted with them and kept in touch
with them in the agile process,
then the chances of lead break goes down
and we'll understand that a little better.
The first thing to be done is understand
the business goals.
And as an architect,
we assume you got enough seniority,
either in knowledge or in years,
and you've understood the...
Requirement of the client properly.
You will now try to correlate the
business goals.
with the requirements and if the
requirements don't seem to match the
business goals.
Then you do some soul searching.
A typical question I'll end up asking a
CEO is.
You are asking for this?
As a business,
what are you going to achieve by this?
And then this is, you know,
actually I myself not very clear.
Then we say, OK,
let's get clear because what you're
asking for.
Is going to be very expensive in terms of
resources? So, no, no,
I was not interested if it is going to be
expensive in terms of resources.
I thought, since we are doing this,
we might as well do this. I said, no,
that's alright.
If it is might as well do it, we'll do it.
But let's try to connect it with what
you're going to achieve as a business,
where it's going to bring in money for
you.
How are you going to use this
functionality?
Where will this functionality fit into
your plans?
ANAND.
When you start connecting with the
business goals,
you gradually find that the requirements
become clearer.
they get properly prioritized and you
understand why you are doing what you're
going to be doing.
And sometimes you have misunderstood the
requirement. You thought it was something,
but when you try to understand in terms
of the business goals and you find that
it wouldn't have been quite that,
then you realize that the way it was
expressed
It carried a different meaning.
And you may have drawn some very
sophisticated charts and diagrams and
flows and made report layouts.
But it's a reality that the clients may
not have looked at them in as much detail
as you would like them to.
Because you've given so much at a time.
that they've not been able to react.
If you gradually open up the envelope,
things will be understood better.
Then we capture this ESRs.
ESRs is architecturally significant
requirement.
Architectures significant requirements.
Some requirements have an impact on
architecture, some don't.
So.
You try to figure out which of these
requirements will.
require an approach where the
architecture will have to be designed to
take care of them.
And when you understood these
requirements.
Decisions.
For these requirements need to be taken
early.
That is what we mean by that
architectural decisions have to be taken
early in the product development life
cycle.
Sometimes,
if some of these architectures decisions
don't need to be taken early,
we don't freeze them.
We keep them open.
We have an architectural review,
and then we freeze it.
And...
With these architectural significant
requirements, we work at a utility tree.
So utility tree is nothing but quality
attributes. Under quality attributes,
various scenarios.
So.
You capture these significant
requirements into a utility tree,
where we'll draw.
Very scenarios.
Suggest certain.
Requirements as understood by the,
we'll go into more detail on these
scenarios again.
We've discussed scenarios when we talked
about tactics.
Those very scenarios we have to put forth
and connect them with quality attributes
and this connection between the
quality attributes and the scenario,
and then deciding which of the scenarios
are difficult to implement,
which of the scenarios are important to
the business.
They normally take the scenarios and we
say that there's significance as far as
the business is concerned to be high,
medium, or low.
And.
The impact on architecture could be high,
medium, or low.
So if the impact is high and the need by
the business is high,
this goes into very high priority of
implementation.
So could you please repeat,
could you please repeat the concept of
Lulu, what are you doing? Yep.
the utility tree once again?
Yeah, I will, in fact,
by the end of this session,
and then we'll take up an example also,
it'll come out clear. But at this stage,
all I want to tell you is the utility
tree, it's a horizontal tree. Normally,
a tree would be vertical. Okay,
this is a horizontal tree where you have
the quality attributes, yeah.
performance, availability, security,
maintainability, et cetera.
And under each of these,
you've got scenarios.
Scenarios are the scenarios we have
discussed in our previous two sessions on
quality. And for each of these scenarios,
we will indicate the business impact and
the architectural impact.
And the business impact could be high,
medium, low,
and the architectural impact could be
high, medium, low.
Okay.
So having understood it,
we designed a strategy.
We want to.
achieve a particular set of objectives.
So when we draw out this utility tree,
you might have around 20 scenarios, one,
two, three, 4, 5, 6, carry on up to 20.
And belonging to different quality
attributes, performance,
this belong to availability,
this belong to security.
And we will take examples of this.
We've got some nice examples we'll take
up later where we'll see how these
scenarios can be described.
Having described the scenarios,
you work out strategies and say you have
strategy X, Y, and Z.
Strategy X probably takes care of this,
this, and this scenario.
Strategy Y takes care of only one
particular scenario.
Z may take care of this, this, and this.
So when you come out with an architecture,
it is...
Not as if you're going to be able to find
one solution fit all. Okay,
these are the problems. I'm A magician.
I'll give you a solution.
It'll take care of everything that you
have thought of. It's not going to happen.
Even out of what you want to attend,
an architectural strategy will be able to
handle only a few of them.
And...
You have to see the value in attending to
a few of them and then try to see
whichever gets the best value. Again,
that's something we'll be discussing in
further detail.
There's something called an
attribute-driven design method.
Did we say attribute? In this case,
we are talking about quality attribute.
And when we talk about design method,
we are talking about an architectural
strategy.
We'll work out architectural strategies
and we will correlate it with the quality
attributes or the exact scenarios it is
going to be able to.
Focus on.
And we will study.
The steps in an architectural-driven
design.
Let's take a look at documenting Software
Architectures.
By the end of this course.
You, you will be expected, actually,
at this stage, let me mention to you,
there's going to be an assignment popping
up in the next one week, and...
In fact, the course handout is revised.
Let me see if I can share the course
handout.
There's a part of the course handout I
want to show you.
Okay, there's a.
Let me give you a glimpse of this.
Here you are.
So this,
the course handout which is up in
Takshila, it will undergo a change,
you will get done,
unless they've already given you the new
one or they'll give it to you in a day or
two.
This is going to be the course handout.
So EC1.
The quiz.
Appear for any 8 out of 14,
average of best 8 will be taken.
These are online quizzes,
they'll add up to 15 marks.
Each one you get approximately one week.
Right from 25th July up to 21st November,
you'll continue having these quizzes.
Then you'll have an assignment which is
called experiential learning,
which means you've got to involve.
your work environment or your personal
exposure to software systems to be able
to attend to these assignments.
The handout will be put up in Takshila in
the next week or so.
And the first assignment is 5 marks.
10 days between August 27th and September
7th. It will be put up in advance,
but you can upload it during this period.
And again,
don't wait for the last date because you
cannot say you were sick on the 7th,
so you could not upload.
If you're sick on the 7th,
you should have uploaded on the 27th of
August because it will be.
made available to you about a week in
advance.
So by the end of this week,
you will get the assignment.
Then you have experiential assignment two,
which is in October.
11th and 25th. Again,
this will be given to you well in advance.
After your first assignment is over,
you get your second assignment.
And then there'll be an online forum chat
in eLearn.
It should be worth 5 marks.
We will divide the class into groups and
you will be expected to discuss what you
uploaded.
So your fellow students will be asking
you about the assignment.
You will be discussing.
how things happen in whatever you have
presented.
So it's not something as if you can just
upload it and forget it.
You'll have to face up to a little bit of.
..
exchange with fellow students,
and you'll be observed by faculty who
will evaluate you and give you marks
based on your maturity of response,
your quality of response,
and on the maturity and quality of the
questions you ask.
And you have to do it all in typing on
eLearn. It's not going to be
Spoken.
So this 15 plus 15, 30 marks is EC1.
close book 30 marks is for EC2 and EC3 is
40 marks. Oh, this is 2 hours,
this is 2 1/2 hours. Okay,
so you got your answer here.
And I strongly recommend they should
distribute your time.
Depending on the marks for a given
question.
So, I go back from here, I...
Stop the sharing and I get back.
Okay,
so you will notice that when I give you
the slides, you are allowed to go forward,
backward and see the slides.
We'll take a 10 minutes break and...
You can go through the slides and take a
look at them.
I'll answer questions after the break,
yeah.
Yes, sure, Chaudhary.
A very relevant question that whether...
So, it should be.
Handwritten or it should be.
Typewritten. Actually,
you'd be given a very specific format,
and in that format you'll be allowed to
type. You won't be able to,
but no copy pasting is possible.
You don't,
you cannot copy paste a drawing.
So if there's a drawing,
you'll have to handwrite it.
But if it is typewritten material,
you can type it in the space that will be
given.
You're going to get a very specific
format for the assignment in this course.
And that will be given to you.
Yeah.
Sure, you're there now? Yeah, okay, good.
So, when you write a documentation...
You must understand who are the users,
who is the audience.
Sometimes we write an architectural
document only for people who make it
onboarded into the project.
On the development side,
sometimes we write it for the...
stakeholders to get the commitment to the
decisions taken.
So you must be very clear whom we are
preparing for and sometimes you may have
to make a separate document for both of
them. If you can make a common document,
all the best.
notations.
There are various types of standard
notations that are available.
We will show you some of the standard
notations.
But as far as this course is concerned,
as long as you can give a glossary saying
that this is the type of notation I've
used to show this, it will be accepted.
We will not ask you to.
Follow any standard notations views.
As I told you,
their structures and their views.
The various types of structures and
corresponding the structure is the view,
the view.
Will depend on the project.
what is important in the project and
which view will be able to express the
project clearly.
So choosing the view plays a very
important role.
Sometimes you will give a combination of
views and we will see one example,
Crutch's 5 view example.
A combination of views gives you a
complete.
idea of what the architecture is going to
be like.
It's not that you have to give every view,
but certain views become important
depending on which aspect of the
application you want to present.
Then you build a documentation package,
which you say these are things we give
good, properly behavior of the.
Application has got to be documented that
what you need to achieve.
Quality attributes have to be very
clearly stated as to what quality
attributes you want to achieve and
describe them in terms of scenarios.
And when I say scenarios,
it means source of stimulus,
acting on an artifact,
giving a response which is measurable,
acting in an environment.
So, this type of a diagram.
to explain very clearly what you're going
to achieve in your architecture.
So.
There can be architecture.
where the requirements change.
And when there's a change in any software
system, it can be local.
Or it could be.
distributed over the entire system.
If it is local,
it doesn't call for any architectural
change.
But if there's a change which the impact
is distributed over the software system,
it calls for a change in architecture.
And requiring this type of a change too
early in the life cycle of an application
is a reflection on poor architectural
study.
If you could not understand that such a
major change is going to take place,
when taking a decision, it definitely is
Not.
Good.
And if there are areas which you want to
secure,
you need to think of them in advance.
In an agile development project.
If you will look at Agile in a while,
but let's put it this way, the...
People of...
The view that having an architectural
decision in the beginning of the project
is contra-agile.
If you go agile,
you're supposed to be adapting,
adaptable to the customer's requirement.
You're willing to change.
And when you say you're documenting
architecture and you're taking decisions
upfront, then you're not being agile.
It is not true. Even to be agile,
certain major decisions have to be taken
upfront. And within the framework,
Of the architecture, you have to be agile,
so agile.
is within an architectural framework.
It is not as if the entire architecture
is left floating.
How much architecture? I mean,
how much should be frozen?
Only that should be frozen,
which needs to be frozen.
You should freeze as much as possible.
So that...
You know the direction where you're
heading.
A parallel in this could be the question
of a building.
You have to decide whether a foundation
could be this is going to be a big
structure.
And this is where you're going to lay
your pillars.
You may make certain changes later,
but where these pillars are going to be
there,
you have to decide how deep these pillars
are going to be.
And once you've done this,
then making changes becomes difficult.
And if you make changes,
the cost implication is huge.
You might have to knock off pillars,
put in new pillars.
Say you're going to make a theater,
you've got to have a large space without
pillars.
How do you make a structure so that it is
allowed, so?
Show me the architecture.
So, being agile with architecture.
means that you need to take whatever
decisions you can upfront and then move
on.
So we'll take up something about agility
and we'll talk about the guidelines for
agile architecture.
It's not the strongest of a species that
survive.
It's the most intelligent that survive.
It is the one that are most adaptable to
change that survive. So.
You need to have software systems which
can adapt.
You need to have developers who can adapt.
and according to the changing requirement.
So this is the same thing is being
repeated.
You have to respond to change.
Responsive to the stakeholders.
So quicker to develop functionalities
that the user cares about.
You prioritize what needs to be developed.
Take those up in priority,
but within the architectural framework.
Try to show early progress.
Agile always says take up the items and
priority.
Having fixed the outline of the
architecture,
deliver as quickly as possible.
the things that are most important so
that you start getting a return on
investment on your application.
Don't wait for the entire application to
be ready.
And if you can have part of the
application ready and running and the
user starts getting the return on it,
you will get more meaningful feedback and
you'll be able to take it into account.
in your future development without having
a late break.
So early progress in the life cycle is
important.
And you should be less burdened by
documentation aspect.
on items which are likely to change.
So documentation is required,
but it should be minimal.
In this way,
architecture and agility do not conflict
with one another.
So the question,
should I go agile or should I have an
architecture which is frozen? No,
they go hand in hand.
We don't say that they are actually happy
companions and...
We actually can have architectural
decisions within an agile framework.
You freeze only to the extent that needs
to be frozen.
There is a website called Agile Manifesto.
dot O RAJ.
Those of you who are in a position,
you can try typing this agile manifesto.
org. Let me try.
A GILEMANIFESTO.
dot ORC.
So those of you who have been able to
type it out would have seen a page where
exactly these items appear.
And if you are not, oh yeah,
there you are.
So, you'll notice that...
Conventionally in IT or in development
life cycles,
we have given a lot of importance to the
item on the right hand side.
Processes and tools,
you need good processes, good tools,
your training programs.
You like to have neat and clear-cut
documentation signed by the people
involved. You'll have a proper contract.
against which you'll do your work.
And they say, plan at leisure,
implement in haste,
have a proper work plan, take it up. Now,
when agile.
framework comes up, they say yes,
these four things are important.
You must have good process and tools,
but no point having good process and
tools if you have good,
if you don't have good individuals,
capable resources,
and you have a good interaction between
all the stakeholders.
So interactions and individuals are given
prime importance in an agile framework.
Comprehensive documents are important.
But working software is more important.
If you can present limited
functionalities in a working condition,
you start getting far more meaningful
feedback.
And people understand what you're going
to deliver from the item you deliver
itself.
You don't have to show them documentation
to show what you'll deliver.
And you should you deliver minimal sets,
and when you deliver these minimal sets,
you get feedback and you correct that.
If you give something in a document,
people don't even understand very clearly
what you are trying to present.
Next is customer collaboration.
You have a signed document,
but then you work with a good rapport
with the customer.
You document your changes.
You have a change control board.
You make proper notes on what changes are
required.
You will negotiate the changes.
But it's important to be open to changes.
You don't just swear by a document,
sign once, and you leave it at that.
And a proper relationship with the
customer will bring forth longer
relationship. And then, yes,
planning is good.
But even within the plan,
you must built in the capacity to respond
to changes. If the target is moving,
you're just going to be shooting at the
place where the target was in the
beginning. So this Agile framework,
some of the who's who in the area of
software development are listed there.
I think they met in the early 1990s and
they developed this and it has changed
the looks of the software industry
thereafter.
You will not believe how much late break
we used to have in the early days.
These are 12 agile principles.
They're very easy to understand.
They're based on the manifesto.
Please read through them at your leisure.
I will not read it for you.
Initially, people thought that...
Agile was contract to the software
development life cycles that were
followed by corporates.
There, you have proper analysis, design,
coding.
Delivery.
And...
People felt agile when things would go
wrong. So in the beginning,
it came up only for small projects.
Is a small project, okay, understandable,
working in a cohesive group,
a group of people who understand things
properly, self-panish. They work agile.
But gradually, it has been realized that
even for large projects.
Particularly where the there's a
distributed development,
there are a number of modules to work
with.
The architecture has designed separate
subsystems. Agile seems to work very well.
How much architecture?
Upfront design.
is required to be able to have a broad.
layout of what work you'll be doing,
what will be the subsystem,
how will you deploy people within that.
you have a lot of flexibility in your
decision making.
So there's a trade-off as to how much
decision in the beginning,
how much flexibility to be allowed.
No.
These things are projected against each
other,
and you take a look at this diagram.
Take a careful look,
and then I'll explain it to you.
This stick.
If you...
Spend a lot of time.
For architecture and risk resolution,
then I say...
Spending time on architecture and risk
resolution is in the beginning of the
project,
spend a lot of time interacting with
stakeholders, designing architecture,
taking decisions as to how the overall
structure of the system will be.
Trying to understand what risks are going
to be there,
find solutions for the risks in advance,
make a backup arrangements, transfer risk,
whatever you got to do, so...
If.
If you put more and more time into this,
the overall project time will increase
proportionately.
Whatever time is 400 degrees.
If I put in more time into architecture,
that there'll be an increase in the time
required for a project now.
Let's stick.
This was the time required, say,
for a small project.
Ten KSLOC, this is 100 SLOC project,
and this was a.
10,000 SLOC project.
So.
If you put in more and more architecture.
This is the amount of time which is
required for rework.
So rework means the amount of time spent
to do work where the clients refuse to
accept what you've given and you want to
make corrections.
So if you spend more and more time on
architecture,
DUTTA.
Time that has to be spent on rework keeps
going down.
In a small project,
as such the project was small,
how much would it go down?
It can't go down much.
A medium-sized project.
It goes down this way on a very large
project.
If you spend more time on architecture.
The rework time, theoretically speaking,
your rework time should come down to zero
if you spend a lot of time on
architectural work and interaction with
the stakeholders,
understanding the requirements,
and in an agile way, attending to them.
Normally at this stage, people have...
Questions?
So anybody who is finding it confusing,
it is best if you speak up.
OK, what is SKSLOC? It is kilo,
kilo means 1000 software lines of code,
so...
One of the basic ways of measuring.
The amount of work to be done on a
project is 1000 software lines of code.
Yeah, 1000 lines of software code.
Of course,
the more advanced projects or more
advanced working teams,
they use something called function points.
Function points is a practice which has
been promoted by IBM in their Rational
Software Group.
But do you appreciate that as you put in
most effort into software?
The rework will reduce.
because you are interacting with the
customer properly, you're taking feedback,
attending to it. So rework will reduce,
but the software cost will increase. Now,
let's add up these two.
In a very small project, if you add up...
A plus X, this line is called a + x.
It just goes upward.
So, in a small project,
it is not worth putting in this type of
effort,
because the effort involved in all these
interactions.
Will actually increase your total work,
so you might as well do rework.
It's accepted as a small project,
better to do the rework in a medium-sized
project.
In the beginning, the cost will go down,
the total of this plus this,
but then it'll start going up.
So a certain amount of...
Agility architectural work is meaningful
in a medium-sized project,
but in a very large project.
If you add up,
this hotspot comes somewhere here,
which means large projects,
they justify good architectural planning.
where you plan out the architecture,
you decide your sub-modules,
decide who will do what work,
what will be the role of every sub-module,
how will sub-modules interact with each
other,
what functionality you performed in which
module, what will be done in each layer,
or maybe which will be done in the server,
what will be done in the client.
If it's a distributed setup,
what work will be done by the proxy?
What will be done by the server?
How will you balance load?
All these things in a large project,
if you work out,
there's going to be a significant ceiling.
So these are called hotspots, this point,
this point.
And here the hotspot is in the beginning
itself.
I called it a hotspot.
The author calls it a sweet spot.
So for large projects,
it justifies a significant involvement in
architecture.
You'll cut down the cost significantly.
Then, agility.
What does agility have to say about
document?
If nobody needs a document,
don't prepare it.
And need is not from a contractual point
of view. The contract says,
you will document so and so and give it
to collect your payment.
You should reach an understanding with
the customer that said,
this is meaningless.
We are preparing the document only to get
the payment.
It is neither required by you to
understand what we are doing,
nor do we need it to do what we are doing.
So what documentation you need to
maintain as a development team?
You'll definitely maintain,
you'll have an architecture structure,
you will write down some flow diagrams,
and you'll use it within your team
because it helps you to train new people
who add into the team or to run the
overall project.
But...
If it is something which is required to
show to the stakeholders,
you'll prepare it.
But document just for the sake of filling
a library should not be done.
That's what the child says.
Agility and architectural evaluation.
Architectural evaluation becomes a part
of the agile process.
You have meeting with stakeholders.
Agility promotes meeting with
stakeholders.
It says that you should always be in
touch with stakeholders.
Keep them up to date.
Let them know what decisions you are
taking.
And architectural analysis is right in
the beginning.
Sit down with the stakeholders and decide
your priorities. Why, what you want done?
How much of which quality attribute do
you require? How will we achieve that?
And get the architect,
the stakeholders involved in the decision.
And this process of meeting the
stakeholders.
We will study,
we will have a class on architectural
trade-off analysis method.
How we go about sitting with the
stakeholders and deciding?
On the trade-off, straight-off means.
TOM.
how much of quality,
how much of performance,
how much of availability.
And trade-off means if you want better
performance,
you might have to sacrifice security.
You want more security,
you'll probably have poorer performance.
And a short form of this architectural
evaluation in time is called a
lightweight architectural evaluation.
We'll see both of them in a subsequent
session.
If I find time,
I'll go back and we'll go through the 12
points of agile.
So.
Will you go in for a say of web?
Welcome, Anupam. Thanks for staying on,
but you can follow the recording for the
rest.
Web conferencing system. In fact,
I can quite appreciate that this is an
out of schedule class in any case.
So it will be difficult for people to
stay on.
If the stakeholders, architects,
and developers found they need to think
and work in two different modes at the
same time: top-down design,
bottom-up design. So,
top-down means we've taken up the overall
requirement and try to...
Give an outline,
and then try to work out in greater and
greater details at the same time.
PRAJJWAL,
where have you picked this up from?
Hi, sir.
Is it from one of my slides?
Have you picked this up from a slide?
Yeah, actually.
Pardon, sir,
I did not actually get a question.
Have you picked this up?
Have you picked this up from one of the
slides, or is it from Outlook? OK.
Yes, yes, sir, yes, sir, yes, sir.
You know,
so I actually asked in the chat about how
do we actually read that graph. So,
Mister Abhinav replied with an answer
where I did not actually understand one
of his points where he mentioned that the
optimal balance shift right to around 20
to twenty-five percent upfront.
Architectures investment to minimize oral
project.
Who, who has written this?
Who has written this? Who?
Mister Abhinav Mukherjee has written this
answer to me, sir, in the group.
So that I will request Abhinav Mukherjee
to answer this.
Yeah, thanks a lot, sir.
Yeah, ab enough.
Why do 20 to 25% irrespective of project
size?
Sorry, sir. So this is, you know,
I was trying to understand the graph.
Oh.
So as per graph,
this is just a explanation that if the
project size is small,
it is not worth investing much on the
time, right?
And if it is like a medium size...
Correct.
project,
then the sweet spot or the hotspot that
we were shifting, it shows around, yeah,
it shows around 25%. I mean,
Yeah, that would be around 25 percent,
25 percent.
this is not a rule of thumb,
but generally it is shown from the graph.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And if it is a, you know, bigger project,
which a lot of overhead and all,
generally it's worth investing in upfront
architecture.
so as to minimize rework at the later
point of time.
Right, right, right.
All we are trying to bring out is that
the larger the project,
it is better to do a little bit of
advanced planning. Okay,
let's go completely off from software.
You are planning to have dinner for you
and your spouse. Number one,
Yes, sir.
you are planning to have dinner for the
entire family of 50.
Next,
you're planning to have a dinner for 1000
people on your wedding.
If you start having the type of planning
that you have for people waiting for a
dinner between you and your spouse,
you'll go mad.
Yes.
And people call you mad.
You don't need to do any planning.
Whatever is then,
take it out and eat it up. Period.
Yes.
Your stomach is full.
If your family of 10 is coming,
Yep.
you might do a bit of planning night
before you sit down,
make sure everything is available in the
house, go to the market,
pick up some things,
make the food and it's ready.
M.
But if there are 1000 people coming for a
wedding, you better have proper planning.
You will have an event planner,
you will have a caterer,
you will decide the menu,
you will test the menu. Good idea.
Understood, sir, yeah.
So that's exactly what we are saying in
terms of software.
Sir, actually,
the question I wanted to ask Mr.
Abena was that,
where he mentioned that the optional
Right.
optimal balance shifts right to around 20
to 25% upfront architecture investment.
I did not actually get the statement.
So, okay,
you look at the diagram that I'm showing
you now. He's in the lower axis.
Yes.
Okay.
The hotspot in a medium-sized project is
around 2025.
So gradually as a project moves up,
in a mediocre project,
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
it moves up to 2025%. And a large project,
it may even go up to 40%.
OK, sir, understood now, yeah.
Okay, so you increase your,
as the project becomes bigger,
you invest more in planning and advance
decisions.
Okay, so how?
You look at it this way, yeah.
A caterer for a wedding,
if your plate is going to cost you 2000
rupees,
the same plate at home for a meal with
your spouse,
you'll make it for 400 to 500 rupees.
Understood. Sir, how often?
If you, if you hire a cook,
it'll cost you probably 800 rupees or
1000 rupees, yeah.
Understood. Sir,
how often do architectural changes happen
in products that are largely used by the
consumers, such as Netflix or Indra?
Yeah, tell me, what example did you take?
Sir,
I think I took Netflix and Myntra or yeah.
Okay, Netflix. Okay,
let's let's take Netflix.
Netflix in its initial days had a lot of
outreach.
Okay.
Okay,
there were crashes people were not being
able to access. What did Netflix do?
They came up with a concept which has
Uh-huh.
become a standard for all the industry
now, content delivery network.
It's a complete change in architecture.
Okay.
What is Content Delivery Network?
If you're not familiar,
please read it on the net.
They make the content available closest
Yes, sir.
to the endpoint,
depending on the preferences of every
endpoint. See,
most of the Banglar content will be
consumed around Kolkata.
Ohh, yes, sir, yeah.
Okay,
in India you will have a lot of Hindi
content,
so there's no point beaming it from
Seattle.
Understood.
So these are architectural decisions.
So when you are setting up a new setup,
these decisions,
if the more you can take them up front,
you will cut down the problems that you
will face later.
And it is a vision that is required of an
architect and his experience,
or her experience,
That will help you to make these
decisions early.
Understood, sir.
And that's why I keep telling you that,
what are you going to do about these
things from an examination point of view?
It's a question of understanding this,
being able to apply it in life,
and examination happens on the way. To me,
no examinations or quizzes or assignments
are just a way.
of getting you to devote some time on the
course. It calls your attention, you,
okay,
let's think about the course for
something. Beyond that,
it doesn't serve much. And you know,
different people, you know,
there's a guy who met me,
a businessman who lived in my building,
my previous setup. He tells me that.
Professor JABBAL, you know so many things,
you know, but we people,
we are businessmen.
If I know one of the things that you know,
I can convert it into crores of rupees.
See,
look at the outlook is altogether
different. He's appearing in an exam.
M.
Understood.
So his exam is,
the marks are measured in terms of money
he earns.
And he's going to convert one piece of
Yes, sir.
knowledge into a lot of money.
So some people who will target the exam,
they will know exactly this type of
questions can come, get the score.
And I'm not saying being able to get good
marks in an exam is bad.
I myself have got very good marks in my
exams.
Yes, sir.
at some stage. But then your study,
you got to distribute it between
examination and knowledge.
And there are lots of things you need for
knowledge.
You know that a question will never come.
But still,
if you have that knowledge in the long
run, it carries you.
So these things have got to be just
understood, that's all.
Understood, sir.
Yeah, okay. Got it. Thanks A lot.
So, then we talk about trade-off.
See, there's something called a spike.
If you're a software developer,
you'll be doing something called POC,
a proof of concept.
But when you're talking about
architecture,
we don't call it proof of concept,
we call it a spike.
There's a major decision to be taken.
and you are taking a decision to achieve
a certain objective.
So what you do is you do a dummy project,
you try the route or you investigate and
find out what is the impact of the
decision on the quality attribute that
you're planning to focus on.
So we call that a spike.
And spikes help you to make these
decisions, answer questions.
Should I move it to a certain type of
database?
Whatever latency am I likely to get?
What type of, if I want skip scalability,
what will it be better for me to shift to
mod pull versus standard pull?
Should I use Java?
Should I use the Python?
Now,
if you're working on an AI project which
is dynamic in its development itself,
the complete change in approach is going
to take place and you want to try out
various options. Definitely Python.
But if you're writing an industry-grade
program which is not going to change,
but you want a faster response,
you will go for Java.
If you want even faster response,
you want them to control the machines and
the machine should react in real time.
You'll probably go for C or C embedded
coding.
Irony is that even these decisions are
architectural decisions,
whether to use Java, to use C, use Perl,
use Python,
and depending on the situation,
the architect has got to be able to keep
got to be capable of taking these
decisions.
So.
You have.
How should the how many participants can
you host on a single meeting server?
We are having these.
The Ms. TEAMS meetings, and today Ms.
TEAMS is being able to handle a large
number of.
Students concurrently logged in.
And this has not been easy.
It's not more than 10 years back.
that the only software that could handle
a class of, say,
this software architecture,
I have taught it in a class of 1400
people.
Because this used to be a compulsory
subject across a number of branches.
And we could only handle it over WebEx.
But today, Ms.
TEAMS also handles it very smoothly.
So, these are...
bringing in technology,
distributing the loads,
integrating things in such a manner that
you can sort of scale to those levels.
And.
What type of servers?
You have servers of various types.
You have meeting servers,
you have database servers,
you have got messaging servers.
Then you have servers for certain graphic
processing. So how will you distribute it?
Will you use the same machine for as a
web server and as a database server,
or will you have it on separate servers?
Whether you will have read and write
access.
Two database on the same server,
or will you have multiple read servers
and one write server?
The syllabus as per handout and the new
handout is up to CS8.
SINDHURA, does it answer your question?
So, can you come again, like, like that?
Up to CS8 to review on CS4.
Yes, OK.
Okay.
So most probably we'll do only up to CS8
before that exam.
Sometimes we'll end up doing something
extra.
The favorite question people ask is,
here there's no gap between the regular
exam and the makeup. Sometimes, you know,
we finish CS9 before the makeup.
So they ask,
do we have to have a separate exam?
Separate syllabus for makeup. No,
it is it is the same syllabus.
Sir, like, according to that, like, yeah,
telling like CSI is something according
to the PPT, like that, like our class PPT,
it would be.
Again, let me, let me take a look.
Let me take a look. Let me confirm.
Architectures confirmation testing and
reconstruction, right?
Architectures, conformance, testing,
and reconstruction.
Okay,
and your PPT will also be that way only.
That is CS it.
We are on CS4 today,
and the topic is capturing
architecturally significant requirements.
CS5 will be architectural design,
6 will be documenting software
architecture,
7 will be layered architecture,
guideline for different layers,
and 8 will be architecture conformance
testing and reconstruction.
Okay, so this is the syllabus.
Okay.
So, let's move forward.
So this says that.
We don't have to.
Either modify agile practices or
interaction methods, they go hand in hand.
So some points have been put down as a
guideline for agile architecture.
Just a minute, Joe.
So the thing that you discussed about the
spikes and the requirement spikes,
Good.
those are just a POCs, right?
Kind of a POCs.
Their POCs at the subsystem level.
Subsystem.
POCs are, yeah, see,
when we talk about POC,
it's a programming concept.
You write a program to see whether a
Okay.
particular activity works or not.
But when we talk about architecture,
Yeah, yeah.
we talk of spikes. They're just like POCs.
For example, you might like to...
get details of how Hadoop will handle the
load.
So you might like to see some case
studies of Hadoop,
Mmh.
or you might just try out a load on
Hadoop to see whether Hadoop can handle
this type of activity or not.
if you have not done it before.
So you joined a company and you believe
that the right database file storage
would be Hadoop storage for you,
a distributed storage. So you try it out.
That is called Spike.
or say you are not getting,
your availability is suffering,
and you decide that to improve your
availability,
you're going to have some sort of an
automated pipeline which will
automatically generate incidents.
for your incident management team.
to be able to make corrections and in any
problem that your server is facing.
So when you...
Think of.
this type of situation,
then you tell the programming will take
some time,
it will take some time for the
application to be ready,
but you set up a small team,
you say please try this out.
try to create a dummy pipeline and see
whether we can create a incident
So.
management system to handle any break
during deployment.
Yeah.
So,
when we create these spikes as an
architecture software architecture team,
do we do we present or discuss those
Right, right, right.
spikes then with our stakeholders or the
business?
Sometimes it may become necessary to
prove to your stakeholders that it works.
After all they are involved in your
decision making,
Okay.
they're going to pay the money.
And you might want it for yourself to be
All right.
sure that you are telling the client I'll
deliver. And even before...
committing it to the client,
you might like to test it once.
The situations I do.
So, for testing,
there needs to be a practical
demonstration,
but this spike is something that this is
a design on a paper.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's actually practically done.
You do a spike practically,
actually demonstrate to yourself.
O.K.
Okay, it's absolutely like a POC.
You can use the word POC also for that,
Okay.
but normally the POC is a programmer's
jargon. It's not an architect's jargon.
And we use Spike in any agile setup,
people who are working in...
Scrum, they also talk about spikes.
So it's just a question of different
jargon from a different world.
It's very similar.
I would love to Google and find out the
fine print,
what is the exact difference between a
POC and a spike.
But I'm looking at spike more at an
architectural level as a subsystem,
whether it works or not.
And when I see POC, I will...
be thinking in terms of an exact
programming construct.
So is it always the subsystem or it can
be a it can be a complete system? No,
Yes.
it can't be a complete system because we
are still at the beginning.
Everything is a subsystem.
Everything eventually is a subsystem.
And when we are talking about an
architecture, we take the system,
we break it up into subsystems and start
planning.
The system will become available only
when all the subsystems are working,
isn't it?
Yes, yes, yes.
Now,
this entire system may be a subsystem in
a larger world.
It's almost like saying that planet Earth
is a part of the solar system.
And then someone tells you, no,
the solar system is a part of the Milky
Way galaxy.
So there's no end to it where it is
system or subsystem.
But when we are talking about
A particular system,
we are concerned about the behavior of
subsystems,
because put together they were to perform
it as an architecture, right?
And our main consultant architecture is
putting subsystems together,
Got and got.
not getting programs working.
Programmers have got to conform to the
architecture.
That once architect is fixed up,
that this is how the subsystems are going
to be there.
These modules are going to perform this
thing. Then the designers,
the software designers,
start designing the software where they
decide what are the classes,
what are the subclasses.
What coding will be required?
What will be the sequence diagram?
What will be the flow of the program?
That is the job of a software designer,
not of the architect.
But the software designer must conform to
the outline fixed by the architect.
So you could read this author's advice
and there's a summary.
We have exceeded our time. Good night.
Sorry folks for holding you up so late in
the night.
Tomorrow is a working day for all of you.
Anyway, we are through it. Goodnight.
Thank you very much, everyone.
I wish you all a good night.
Thank you.
Thank you. Bye.